I think it's totally possible to have a
totally autonomous Robo taxi service in
2025 2026
but people need to be testing on edge
cases
[Music]
all right we'll start with the most
difficult thing tell me who you are and
what you do all right so I am chess
Stetson
um I have a background in computational
neuroscience and I am the CEO of d-risk
and what we do is train and test and
then retrain self-driving cars on edge
cases all the hard uh unusual things
that can happen on the road which
individually are unlikely but together
make up all of the risk so when you get
in a traffic accident it's not because
you're doing something totally normal
it's because something unusual happened
and even that that unusual thing is very
very unlikely all the unusual things
together those are the things we need to
get self-driving cars to get good at and
you know you spoke earlier about um talk
to me about the difference between
solving this outside in versus inside
out so
if you were talking with pretty much any
engineer over a pint
that engineer would agree with you that
the thing with any engineering problem
is to solve for the edge cases for the
things that happen on the boundary the
hardest stuff and then you usually get
the easy stuff for free another way I
might put it is if you can learn to
thread a needle then it's really easy to
thread a basketball hoop but not vice
versa
and so if we had a principle for getting
a self-driving car to solve everything
that was hard unprotected left oncoming
Vehicles T-Bones times when people are
wearing unusual camouflage we solve for
all of those things then it would be
easy to also solve for just driving down
a straight road with two lines behind on
either side
um uh you know taking protected turns
the problem is that self-driving car
companies have generally been
incentivized to do the easiest stuff
first they have gotten it so that they
it seems very impressive when you get a
car to just stay between the lanes
because it feels like wow like it's uh
it's just like we do as humans but you
you as a human don't then remember that
it's so uh so difficult to repeat
everything that a human already takes
for granted all the millions of years of
evolution that have that have allowed us
to be able to avoid oncoming Vehicles
because it's this big scary thing that's
coming at you the self-driving car
doesn't have that intuition so when it
solves for a center case you can't be
sure it can solve for the edge case so
how are
current and driverless car companies how
are they approaching this problem what's
what's their current solution versus
what do risk is doing now they all know
they need to solve for the edge cases
but their development trajectory started
with the easy stuff then getting got
more and more complex so now you can do
something very very different where you
can if you could catalog everything that
could go wrong you can actually simulate
it and then train the self-driving car
to handle all of it at once and then you
don't have to go in that stepwise way
and more importantly you don't endanger
people on the road when something
unusual happens how do you define the
limits and the parameters of everything
that could go wrong without going into
the weird and wonderful surrealist world
of elephants falling out of the sky et
cetera etc etc well in principle we
allow for that so we don't draw the line
anywhere we certainly have meteor
strikes sitting inside of the knowledge
graph
um and people often bring that up as
like what do you have to solve for that
you actually kind of do because a media
will often have a bright flash that
happens in the atmosphere you need to
make sure that your computer vision
doesn't misinterpret that as something
else yeah so
um we don't draw the line at any
particular phenomenology if you if you
have a particular simulator it'll it'll
have to only simulate certain things
right so Grand Theft Auto can simulate
and an end set of things but it might
not be able to do the meteor
what we do is first catalog everything
that can happen and we do that by taking
data from all the sources that can tell
us about real life accidents and about
what goes wrong with autonomous vehicles
and AI we put them in one massive
catalog which is called a knowledge
graph for us something a data structure
that's so flexible that it can capture
just about anything that can happen even
if it happens only in schematic form and
then we pipe those into simulation
picking always the things that most
canvas the landscape of everything that
can go wrong in such a way that you can
train the autonomous vehicle and then
test it later with an independent set
and that is the the whole flow that you
need in order to be able to capture all
that weird stuff and make sure that AV
can handle it so what kind of data
sources are you capturing then you
mentioned so some of the big ones are
camera data and accident reports the
camera data comes from things like uh
the good old Jam cams here in London
London's highly sensorized and we've
been aggregating that data for years I
think more than any other company we
also have uh static CCTV cameras in the
US traffic recording cameras and then of
course front-facing cameras from a bunch
of different sources and we focus on
places where accidents actually tend to
happen we just focus on cameras that are
looking at intersections on-ramps
off-ramps a bunch of places where we
know risky stuff is going to happen lo
and behold we got a lot of that risky
stuff then we use computer vision suck
it in and then retrain the self-driving
cars to handle all that risky stuff I
mean how much data have you gathered in
terms of like terabytes like it must be
huge well I put it in terms of the under
some of the underlying data types
sometimes so we have roughly a million
hours of camera data from a variety of
locations mostly static CCTV pointing at
higher risk or or interesting
intersections we've got hundreds of
thousands of accent reports including a
huge amount of full text accent
reporting we have thousands of those
reports that we got from Individual
contributors that were telling us about
you know what they had advised their
kids to avoid and what they think is
going to be hard for self-driving cars
we have insurance reports that tell us
about collisions that might never have
been reported uh in an official police
statement so that's that's a rough scope
of what what it is but then it all needs
to get translated into this this place
where the statistics change again
many of the hours of camera footage
record exactly the same thing as all the
other a bunch of boring driving and so
we all have to we have to translate it
into this this manifold this landscape
so I'm a driverless car company and I
come to de-risk how does the process
work we start by giving you maybe a
thousand of the riskiest edge cases over
the whole span of the the landscape of
edge cases now usually we'll start with
things that are easy for you to simulate
so vehicles and some pedestrians then
when you get good at those then they can
start running many more of them and then
they'll also get more esoteric things
they'll get the bikes and the scooters
they'll get the unusual events certainly
boxes and other kinds of objects falling
off the back of vehicles and that takes
them out to many thousands more and we
believe that the the end game of this is
to get self-driving car companies into
at least the hundreds of millions of
scenarios but the number is not as
important as the distribution they need
to get out to as I might say Six Sigma
of the events so if humans deal with
four or five Sigma of the events we
expect self-driving car companies to
deal with just a bit more uh because
they should be held to a higher standard
yeah and when we talk about the events
and the knowledge graph could you just
talk to me a little bit about how those
each of those crashes and incidents are
cataloged and categorized right so the
self-driving car simulation environment
is kind of like 3D right but the actual
space of everything that go wrong is
many many more Dimensions than that you
can't just imagine that uh just dealing
with things that move in X Y and Z is
enough because of course they can be all
sorts of Arrangements of those things
and those are like more Dimensions
um which ones tend to be coming at you
versus which ones are just going to pass
you those are actually characterized by
dimensions for us what the vehicles are
what what kinds of different objects you
can be looking at
um potentially even human intentions
those are all dimensions for us and you
put all those Dimensions together and
you have at least a thousand dimensional
space and and depending on how we do it
much more than that that ends up going
to this thing that I've been telling you
about this knowledge graph and it's it's
like a hyper dimensional space that you
can then probe to find these stuff
you're most interested in testing on it
so if I wanted to go out and drive on
the road I have to get a provisional
license that says I am testing myself
and I'm learning and then I have to pass
a driving test and then I get permission
to drive on the roads is there that
driving test for driverless cars at the
moment right no you'd think there would
be
um the problem is twofold one the way
you test an AI should be completely
different than the way you test a
regular eye a non-ai
um with a human you go and you do your
driving test and when the driving
instructor sees that you can do parallel
parking with traffic going by he knows
that if the traffic were coming the
other direction you'd be just as able to
avoid it because you've got this brand
that doesn't like to get hit by things
it's been evolving for millions of years
well more than that depending on your
account to not get hit by things and not
to hit things self-driving cars don't
have that they just match patterns it's
in a very sophisticated way but you
can't be sure at all that if a
self-driving car knows how to do an
unprotected left turn while avoiding the
Gap in traffic that you know weaving its
way through the Gap in traffic that it's
going to be able to do the same thing uh
coming out of a residential street onto
a highway if it's been doing in a
junction on two highways so
um and the and again the reason for that
is because it's matched a pattern of
what it's supposed to do and that
pattern may not translate to another
scenario AI isn't good at generalizing
so what a real self-driving car drivers
test would be one that really just tests
the self-driving car on everything that
can happen completely unlike a regular
driving test because there's not enough
time for it but there is one if you can
simulate and and two if you can do it
massively in parallel you still have to
test on the right stuff but there's a
lot more capacity for testing then the
other really important thing is
the test has to be something that's
completely out of sample you can tell a
self-driving car company the kinds of
things that you want to test on but if
you give it exact tests that needs to
pass it'll just learn to do those things
now the question is how safe if I have a
driving test I'm allowed to have some
miners
I don't think anybody's convincingly
answered that question yet our company
is going to be coming out with what we
would call a sigma score in a few months
here and uh the way it works is if you
can map out everything that's going to
go wrong you start with the relatively
more common things in the center and
then you actually move throughout that
map and as you go throughout that map
you get further and further from the
center and you're collecting more and
more things in the same way that we talk
about a bell curve in statistics as you
get out to two Sigma you've handled 95
percent of the uh things three sigma is
99 we think humans are somewhere between
four and five Sigma and a self-driving
car should be Six Sigma and that is
roughly what we think that should be the
bar and so that would that would be how
you know when you're safe
can can this do everything is there a
world in which an autonomous driving
company would never need to test their
vehicles on open roads or is there
always a limit
I think that is exactly the premise that
you shouldn't need to test in an open
road when you deploy it because you
should be so confident in this Behavior
I think that the idea that we've been
hearing from self-driving car companies
for many generations that of these
Technologies now that they're collecting
more data by driving in real life and
then that's going to make them better is
a little bit nuts but then again by the
time you get to a high level performance
perhaps a little bit of testing on the
open road should be like the final
veneer like the icing and the cake the
top of the creme brulee what needs to
happen before that is that you should
see self-driving car companies in some
sort of controlled environment doing
huge gauntlets of tests and they they
should still in real life tests they
should still be out of sample there
should be things that a testing
Authority set up that they couldn't
predict but even there they're going to
have some kind of idea because it's got
to be practically set up it's going to
be a pedestrian dummy or something like
that they're never gonna have to deal
with that so really most of the
confidence needs to come in simulation
beforehand yeah obviously what we're
talking about here is a vision based
Learning System now a lot of the
driverless car companies are also
deploying lidar yeah
um does lidar not just solve this
problem
it I I don't think they're so different
um lidar needs to be able to handle edge
cases just like computer vision does now
they're they're slightly different for
some things in the lidar domain lidar is
going to have trouble handling a bunch
of pipes pointing out at you you know
and the lasers pointing down the pipes
it's not going to see the face it's just
going to you know have a very minimal
signature there or the classic one is
like a hurricane fence that I can't
actually see but it could run into
um the lidar needs to be able to handle
that just like computer vision needs to
be able to handle uh you know a great
Cloud pedestrian and a gray background
they so they have different edge cases
but they they both have edge cases that
are specific to the sensor modality and
then they both have this massive problem
of if somebody is about to walk out from
behind an occlusion and there's a small
amount of time in which to integrate the
information you need to be able to
handle that no matter what so really
having solving the problem of Common
Sense is not specific to a particular
sensor modality lidar is great because
just like a garage door sensor if
there's a physical thing there it can
make you stop but you need to anticipate
whether that physical thing is going to
be there and that's a huge part of the
problem that you can't get around with
any one particular sensor nice so what
is the road ahead upon entirely not
intended but it's there anyway but it
what is what's the next plans for
de-risk
um our goal is to try to get the initial
set of scenarios that we think are the
best representation of the first
thousand or so odd high-risk scenarios
out to basically every AV developer and
then I think we will already start to
see improvements in in the life cycle in
the in the in the trajectory of
autonomous vehicles that we haven't seen
yet I think it's totally possible to
have a totally autonomous robo-taxi
service in 2025 2026
but people need to be testing on edge
cases thank you thank you very much
pleasure